as you grow up as a woman you sort of
presume a certain sort of secondary
nature to things um and
that uh
that you know you're allowed to be
confident and it doesn't mean that you
have to be mean or nasty or you can be
confident and
still proud of yourself and nice
[Music]
hi i'm sarah snook and this is my
glamour unfiltered
i think that uh
they are actually all likeable in some
ways i think they're um they're unusual
and they're um familiar and i think
everybody can relate in some way to
having a family member if not a whole
family like that yeah they might be
unlikable in some ways but there's some
sort of redeeming quality within each of
them
there's a lot of vulnerability in shiv
but
that's something that's also attractive
to me about shiv that she's
that she's somebody who throws that
defense up in a confident way that she's
um able to use humor to deflect or or
just a
terrible kind of blank face
a bit of side eye to deflect
my character in season three develops i
think in the way that she's moving away
from season one and season two uh she
had a career outside of the family and
then she got married and now she's with
her husband inside the family business
and he's inside the family a little more
and i think at this point after
kendall's revelation the journey for
shiv is really about defining who she is
and who she wants to be for this season
[Music]
yeah i think um but i think the same
could be thrown back at kendall i think
uh i think he thinks that he's a good
person but he's not a good person you
know and i think that part of that is a
sibling rivalry and part of that is
probably accurate and truthful on on
both accounts what is the meaning of
good in this family is is maybe a little
more flexible and and permeable than
what is like you know actually good and
altruistic and maybe something more
philanthropic or or just
a better human being outside of this
kind of
vicious roy family i think each of the
characters no matter who they are logan
tom greg
kendall they all think they are good but
not necessarily are
[Music]
i love being able to be
maybe tougher than i am and to be able
to
there's just some actually got some
great lines she's got some
some great one-liners and some great
moments of just uh
it's maybe maybe share a silent opinion
and sharing her opinion silently
whether that's through a bit of a side
eye or or something else it's great
[Music]
i think that's part of the fun is
discovering why they're together and and
the longer we get to play these
characters the more i understand their
history and who they are and who they
are together and and that's also like
what is really fun about that is it's
constantly evolving and developing and
and and jesse and the writing team are
uh
so um
engaged with these characters and trust
us as well to perform
what they throw down for us that um it's
just exciting to see where they're gonna
take us
money doesn't make you happy i think is
what i've learned about wealth and
certainly the roy's interns aren't happy
um in a lot of ways and they are in
others
but i'm not sure that it's money that
makes them happy
and then power power is a is a
corrupting thing i think
absolute power corrupts absolutely is
that old saying and and i think that's
definitely true for the royals
[Music]
we deal with with with promoting female
power in in succession as we would with
any other
uh gender in that um they are equal and
seen as such it's only when it's um a
character element i think for for logan
or for kendall as a moment in episode
two where he um he calls out shiv for
only been valuable for her teats which
is just like it says more about the men
i think in the show that um
decide to treat women differently uh
than it does about the women because
ostensibly they have equal power
[Music]
i think she wouldn't call herself a
feminist but she definitely is feminism
is about equal opportunity and about
being equal to men not having a higher
power or
more power than men and so i think yes
the show is innately feminist because of
that
the the expectation that women are equal
every woman has in some way in some form
um
absolutely and uh but i think that you
know for shiv one of the things that i
love playing her for is that she i have
said this before but she deserves to she
believes she deserves to be in every
room that she's in and that if there's a
glass ceiling for her it's it doesn't
really exist because she's beyond
privilege and beyond money and power
that she can afford to buy the building
and smash the ceiling of that building
in the first place so
yes she might have limitations in some
ways but in some
for shiv i feel that just not
acknowledging those limitations due to
gender means that they don't exist and i
kind of like that it's like
don't engage with it and then it doesn't
exist
[Music]
like everybody does really just have a
good firm chat to them
i sort of developed an older sister
character for a while it was like
you know if i was having a fit about
feeling the right sort of confidence
level that i wanted to it was like well
well what are you gonna do about it
sarah you're gonna just uh you're gonna
complain all day or all night or you're
gonna you know buck up and get out there
and do something you know you can you're
allowed to i acknowledge your feelings
you're allowed to be upset but you know
make a decision just develop a
an alter ego is a little bit more um who
believes in you a little more than maybe
you do at the time
[Music]
kendall is is someone who so more
publicly deals with with mental health
and and his um i guess publicly as his
character uh not necessarily public
facing in the world of the roy's and
succession but um
he's probably the one who goes through
the journeys of of depression and
and ill mental health uh more publicly
than the roys do but i think that
probably it affects each of the
characters in in their own way
[Music]
i love nature and i just get out into
into nature as much as possible and i
think really
growing up in a way that uh
i i had access to nature that was really
important to me growing up that i've
realized now that was an important
element of my childhood
i certainly have always felt pretty
strongly about being proud of oneself
no matter what you look like oftentimes
i find as a woman you're more likely to
be far more cruel to yourself than you
ever are about other people or to other
people and so why can't you give
yourself the grace of kindness as well
and that's not always easy of course
it's not at all
roman for sure like we have such a great
rapport and repertae and you know like
battle in in sort of words and looks and
physically yeah genuinely physically
there's a scene that we have in episode
two where um some donuts arrive and they
get called
irrelevant donuts and then in turns very
relevant donuts and i just love that
these
like that pastries that like sweet
desserts can can be the thing that turns
a whole moment and we had a lot of fun
shooting that scene
i say plastic jesus to kendall at one
point and i think that's perfect
[Music]
yeah great i mean i feel like it's a
really easy halloween costume go out
there and get a red bob wig and see what
you can do but i want to like lay down a
challenge to do a zombie shiv or a
zombie vampire ship or
and maybe like i don't know where will i
be on the 31st i wonder if there's a
potential like disguise i could go out
and as shift and no one would think it
was me because hopefully there's other
ships that i could blend into with
[Music]